je suis un être humain et je mérite le
respect comme n'importe qui en fait dont
toute ma vie je dois prouver deux fois
plus déjà que je devais prouver
énormément du fait que j'avais pas eu de
parents et que j'avais pas confiance en
moi et que je m'aimais pas et là en plus
de ça le peu de choses que j'ai réussi à
mettre en place et il a peu de
construction humaine que j'ai réussi à
faire et ben on me l'a détruit quand on
n'en peut plus de vivre on n'en peut
plus de vivre parce que justement tous
les jours on porte énormément de choses
et les gens le savent pas en fait c'est
juste l'environnement actuel c'est à
dire il y a de la violence c'est
toujours plus trash il y a plus de cadre
l'être humain n'a plus de cadre
aujourd'hui et en fait on se perd et
tout le monde se perd ses missions là
elles veulent quoi elles veulent aller
toujours plus loin en pensant que ça va
faire de l'audience voilà prêt à tout on
détruit pas un être humain on le linge
pas publiquement et qu'est-ce qui se
passe rien pour moi il devrait y avoir
des modérateurs des modérateurs qui
regarderaient les épisodes oui c'est
triste
j'ai passé des super examens j'avais 20
sur 20 on m'a dit non vous êtes une
personnalité publique vous êtes un
personnage public vous êtes un
personnage public avant d'être un être
humain